- I was suffering from post
traumatic stress disorder,
depression and grief.
I was going downhill fast.
- Ketamine's used as a
transformer of moods,
only discovered in the late 90's.
People were very incredulous,
it's an anesthetic,
how could it have
anything to do with mood?
- What is actually happening in the brain
when a person takes this drug?
- I'm always a little
nervous before the injection
'cause I know I have no
control over what my mind
is going to think about.
The trauma that I'm dealing
with, basically unthinkable
but I've lost both of
my children to suicide.
My youngest son, Dylan,
knew that his life mattered,
that he mattered, that he had a voice
and unfortunately, his impulsive nature,
caused him to go in and shoot
himself and end his life.
When I found him, I
screamed uncontrollably.
What I saw, nobody should see.
I ran out of the house
and then ran back in
to make sure he wasn't still alive
even though that's physically impossible
based on what I looked at.
I hired a grief counselor immediately,
I hired the best post traumatic
stress disorder counselor
I could find and I did
pull myself out of it,
I did reengage and I had an older son
who still lived with his
mum and I worried about him
'cause he didn't go to
counseling and he held things in,
he didn't share but he
kept saying he was fine.
We were about to go to the
Edmonton Oilers playoff game
with my dad and my sister
because I really believed
in trying to united the
family, start having us
live our lives again, that
was my obligation to others,
friends and family and my son.
My son was clearly
depressed but he denied it.
And the day before he
was supposed to go back
to see his mother, he
called me on a bike ride
to tell me that he loved me
and I knew something was wrong.
When he asked me how long I was gonna be,
it reminded me of my other son
when he asked me the same question.
When I got home a year ago about today,
I found my other son
dead of a gunshot wound.
(crying)
Needless to say, I fell apart.
Brought in spiritual leaders,
I brought in other counselors.
Any ideas that people
had that could help me
get a grip on my life 'cause
for the first four months, I didn't care
if I was alive, I didn't care if I died.
I didn't think it mattered, I had no hope.
I had no purpose.
It was empty without my kids.
(gentle music)
I first went to some
grief recovery centers,
I went to a brain scanning clinic.
I signed up with an EMDR specialist.
I was severely depressed
trying to get out of it
and I wanted to try to make
some progress on my own
before I came to do the ketamine
and I wanted to get through Christmas.
Having had lost one son
and knowing the worst date
is Christmas, not the birthday,
not the anniversary date of death,
Christmas is the worst date
if you've lost a child.
I knew I had that coming and
I didn't wanna be doing this
or have just done it and
then get whacked again
so I knew to get through Christmas.
If I could get through
Christmas, early January,
I'm flying back into
L.A., and I'm gonna come
and spend two weeks and do this treatment.
And I got through Christmas
and I made it here.
- It's known as special
K, a psychedelic drug
popular in dance clubs but
doctors say the same drug,
ketamine, approved as animal
tranquilizer and anesthetic
can also be a lifesaver when
used to treat severe depression
when nothing else works.
One small study found ketamine
decreased suicidal thoughts
almost immediately in 50% of patients.
Most anti-depressants take weeks.
- Tom was pretty troubled
when he came to us.
He was not dealing at all well.
Tom really was blaming
himself a lot for that
and was suffering a great
deal of guilt and remorse,
pretty unsure about whether
he wanted to continue living.
He had a very rough and
contentious first infusion.
By the day after his second infusion,
he was really just singing
the praises of the treatment.
Ketamine was found to be a
profoundly effective anesthetic
given as a lump or bolus.
It was only when people began to give it
in a very gradual way and
in sub-anesthetic doses
that we realized what
an amazing mood elevator
and reverser of suicidality it is.
It starts a chain reaction,
it actually caused new growth
in connections in the brain
and in receptor density
among those connections.
That patient, who has
an infusion, experiences
a dissociative state, does
not have true hallucinations.
He may see things that
aren't there but he knows
that they're not there.
Dissociation can be very
mild, like when you're waiting
to pay at the grocery
store and you're thinking
about what you're gonna do tonight,
your mind and body are sort of separate.
A lot of patients tell
us that they're able
to do really important internal work
while they're having an infusion.
It can be really therapeutic for them
to have a really objective
perspective on their life
and this dissociation that
Dr. Mandel was talking about,
of course, it's very
important, we're big advocates
of talk therapy and for
them to work through
some of these things with a professional.
- It's a treatment, it's not a cure.
It will not stand alone.
- For me, I'm always a
little nervous before
the injection 'cause I
know I have no control
over what my mind is going to think about.
It can go from very
pleasant to very scary.
I know at the end, I'm
going to feel better.
I'm gonna say it's an
out of body experience.
I'm present watching myself but it's not
in a dimension that I can explain.
They actually let me know that I matter,
that I am good enough.
They gave me tools to discuss
with my conventional psychologist.
(gentle music)
I had moments of emotional
pain from my loss
that I understood why somebody
would wanna take their life.
For whatever reason,
something changed in me
that made me go from
I don't care if I live
to I don't wanna die and now,
because of these treatments,
I can now go and share my
story and let people know
that life is worth living.
That as bad as it gets,
as painful it gets,
we do have a choice and we have freedom
to make that choice.
But I can go out and help
other people possibly
and whether I'm successful
or not doesn't matter,
I'm at least gonna try to do that.
I'm gonna try to give back
what this clinic's given me.
My life.
(light music)